- During the winter school
that will run for three days,
There will be a series
of different sessions.
Some of them will be
plenary talks speaking about
different aspects of the
science of consciousness,
but there will also be some social events.
So you get to interact
with leading researchers.
Leading consciousness researchers.
- It's a unique opportunity
for young scientists
to get engaged with people,
they've read the papers of.
We've all had this
experience as scientists
of actually meeting for the first time
one of the people we admire,
or one of the people we disagree with or
one of the people who influenced our work.
- People get divided
into teams that become
these little communities
and they get to work on projects
and they have a lot of time outside of
just lecture time to interact
both socially and scientifically
and I think that really builds
relationships that last.
- And at the end of it, I
think you'll come away equipped
with a whole lot of skills and experience
that will be really valuable
in your academic career
or in fact, in whatever
you want to do next.